i'm marching because killer kyle should
not be going to this campus that is
i don't know if you like murderers on
your campus but i personally don't i'm
marching because i believe in the
american right to self-defense
i would understand there was more
controversy there was no evidence of
what happened that night but there was
clear evidence that he did defend
himself and the fact that we actually
have opposition just proves the fact
that they either didn't watch the trial
or they just don't love this country we
think kyle should be able to go to
school here and it was proven that he
did nothing wrong facts don't care about
it
[Music]
the american justice system does not
acquit morality they are not the
objective morality in america they are
not nowhere they are founded on genocide
and china slavery their morality is
based in white centrism their morality
is based in white supremacy so the
american justice system does not work
for people outside of that umbrella
he's an american who has committed no
crime he's a
he contributes to society the way any
other american contributes to society
who's not imprisoned so
we should have zero bias towards him
whatsoever of what school he goes to or
where he wants to be educated at because
he was acquitted he has not committed
any crimes so he's free to go where he
wants to go
not here
[Applause]
[Applause]
club on campus i think that they are a
group of individuals that don't
understand what really went on with the
trial and that any of them watch the
trial might sign the changing gender
studies
we're protesting
right
for the second amendment right about the
fifth amendment right of due process
[Applause]